wisst ihr was nerds wirklich aufregt
[Applaus]
nein es gibt so sprüche da fehlt mir als
wissenschaftler einfach der humor
alkohol keine lösung vor bei destillaten
oder auch nach dem physikalischen
gesetzen kann die hummel gar nicht
fliegen aber davon weiß ich nichts und
tut es einfach nichts gegen motivierende
sprüche aber nicht auf kosten der physik
ja ich weiß was der spruch bedeuten
sollen
wieso ist eigentlich glauben es gibt so
viele menschen die das vermeintlich
unmögliche möglich gemacht haben und
gerade in den naturwissenschaften sind
natürlich die entdeckungen die größten
die den status quo der
naturwissenschaftliche gesetze in frage
oder auf den kopf gestellt haben aber
physikalische gesetze sind keine
straßenverkehrs gesetze die man einfach
brechen kann denn in dem moment wo man
sie bricht müsste man sie neu definieren
wenn normale gesetze sowie physikalische
gesetz wären dann wäre das junge frau
sie können nicht bei rot über die straße
geht doch das kann ich sehr wohl dass
etwa gerade nicht gesehen
dann müssen wir das gesetz ändern zum
beispiel die gravitationstheorie nach
newton ist ausreichend für fast alles
was sie hier auf der erde beobachten
aber dann kam irgendwann ein stein und
er verband und seine sagte
in der masse die raumzeit und europa
musste die gravitation neu definieren
wer sich für das thema interessiert kann
sich ein altes video von mir anschauen
aber darum geht es doch gar nicht was
ich damit sagen will jetzt werde ich
diesen apfel hier loslassen würde und
erhöhte nicht nach unten sondern nach
oben
dann müsste man die gravitation aber
fucking hallo noch mal neu definieren
und wenn hummeln die gesetze der
aerodynamik brechen würden dann müsste
man diese schleunigst auch neu
definieren deswegen macht dieser hummel
spruch überhaupt keinen sinn und ja ich
sage gerne sinn machen station ergeben
weil ich finde dass umgangssprache auf
eine sprache ist und dass die sprache
weiterentwickelt und wenn du einen
deutsch welt bist findest du sehr
aufregt dann musst du dein eigenes video
machen aber das hier ist mein neuer
trend wo war ich jedenfalls
physikalische gesetze sind keine
unverbindliche empfehlung der man
nachkommen kann oder auch nicht sie
beschreiben die realität und fliegende
hummeln gehören nun zur realität
ok kommen wir noch mal zu den
physikalischen gesetzen hier so
schändlich zitiert werden der ganze
mythos dass hummeln eigentlich gar nicht
fliegen können geht auf den
französischen insektenforscher und
fragen die man york zurück bzw auf sein
buch der insekten flug aus dem jahre
1934 dort rechnete aus dass ein flugzeug
mit hohem gewicht ist eines vertrages
lächeln größe also müssen ist nicht
fliegen könnte
das stimmt so erstmal und jetzt finde
die täler
[Musik]
genau
hummeln sind keine flugzeuge zum
beispiel bewegen gruppe ihre flügel und
das nicht zu wenig bis zu 2 der mal pro
sekunde
daher kommt auch das geräusch hier gibt
es nicht nicht zu fassen
dabei können die ziemlich versierten
pummel flieger nicht nur schlaufen und
achter schlagen sondern sie können ihre
flügel aufdrehen das heißt ober und
unterseite wechseln was sie auch mit
jedem schlag machen dabei entstehen
kleine luft wirbelströme die so
verlaufen dass ein zusätzlicher auftrieb
entstehe
ansonsten entsteht der auftrieb dadurch
dass die hummel flügel genauso wie
flugzeugflügel gekrümmt sind so dass die
luft oben stelle vorbei ist als unten
das nennt man die den effekt der lässt
sich auch ganz gut mit einem so lang
papier beobachten
seht ihr ich blase über das papier
dadurch wird der luftstrom hier
schneller als unter dem papier dadurch
wieder druck über dem papier geringes
unter dem papier und es entsteht ein
auftrieb
das plus die wir geströmt durch den
geschickten flügelschlag und die hummel
sind völlig durch
so aber am schlimmsten sind die
motivation sgouros die auch noch zahlen
einprägen das bloß die zahlen daraus
zahlen gehören zum wissenschaftlichen
fakten allein ebay hier hier bietet die
rummel kilogramm und hat eine flügel
welche von 1,45 quadratzentimeter und
hier liegt die kugel nur 1,2 gramm und
hat eine flügel von 0,7
quadratzentimeter erstens sehen das
offenbar nicht dieselben zahlt was ja
noch gester hummeln sicherlich
verschieden groß und verschieden schwer
sind aber dann soll man nicht so tun als
wären das allgemeingültige zahlen
und zweitens haben die es hier doch
nicht mal mit dem selben masse zu flügel
flächen verhältnis zu tun
und auch wenn ich denke dass das zweite
beispiel eher der realität eines hummel
körperbaus entspricht den ich damit nur
sagen wenn du jemand motivieren willst
ein aber in einigen nicht die physik in
dem du zahlen verwendest um
sinnlosigkeit zu unterstreichen und wenn
ihr jetzt seit mai das ist doch nur ein
spruch warum regst du dich so auf dann
freunde der sonne seit ihr offenbar
keine not for you
freunde der sonne wenn ihr freunde der
hummeln habt die gerne diesen spruch
benutzen dann wisst ihr was zu tun ist
schickt ihr dieses video und wenn euch
der spruch sonst irgendwo begegnet dann
wisst ihr ab jetzt was ihr zu antworten
habt im namen der physik rage zu live
wir sehen uns nächste woche die bis
dahin bleibt sicher